now imagine you making six night dancing
moves in the opening and still managed
to win the game
sounds very funny yet very interesting
right
welcome guys as in today's lecture you
are going to witness exactly that
[Music]
after E4 and Knight to F6 we enter into
the alkyne defense where by far white
has chosen the move E5
and after Knight to D5
what else but grabbing the space in the
center with D4
okay black challenge the White Center
with D6
and accordingly white grab more space in
the center and still attacking the
Knight with C4
the Knight retrieved back to B6
and since black has pressure on the E
Pawn in the majority of the cases white
has choose the exchange variation which
goes as follow
Pawn takes D6
C captures D6 and now Knight to C3 which
confirms white space advantage
okay now both the side take out the
minor pieces and arrange the castle
so let me go through the main line
G6
Knight to F3
Bishop to G7
Bishop to E3
black Castle on the king side
Bishop to E2
Knight to C6
White Castle on the king's side and the
final move Bishop to G4
where obvious enough both the side are
happy at the stage
well here comes a small trap guys if
your opponent continue with more such as
S3 then after Bishop captures F3
white get a horrible position as by
force he has to take back with the pawn
and compromise his King safety
because if he foolishly take with the
bishop then after Knight capture C4
black wins the pawn and in fact if you
look at the results here they are
tremendous for the black
so nope H3 is a bad move in this
position
by force white has to play B3 in order
to protect the C4 Pawn
and now I recommend this nice jab in the
center with D5
white has two choices and amongst them
taking on difa is a pretty bad idea the
simple reason is after Knight to B4
white get an isolated Queen pawn and a
sample line can goes like this H3 Bishop
takes F3 Bishop takes F3 Knight takes D5
Knight takes D5 and after Knight
captures D5 you can understand what I
mean
this Pawn is a clear-cut Target and what
black wants to do is he wants to put his
major artillery on the D file and then
Munch The Depot
so that's why by far the most obvious
choice from the white is to grab space
on the queen side with C5 and attacking
the Knight
okay we are going to move our aliyaki
Knight fourth time with Knight to C8
which at First Sight looks strange
but guess what we have reached to the
critical position
where if you look at the database here
top three choices H3 Rook C1 and A3 all
leads to our tricky platform
let's see each by Tone and find out what
is the big idea from the black side
the first move I want to consider is H3
highestly played here
but a mistake as after Bishop takes F3
Bishop takes F3 E6 defending the pawn
and White's most obvious choice is to
play A3
so that he can steamroll black on the
queen side
but the matter of factors after Knight
to E7
B4
and now this nice move
Knight to F5 where if you count this
night moment we have done sixth night
Roundup three in the opening stage but
the most important part is when he land
on F5 it wins the game for us
how well the answer is very simple right
now there is a three attacker on the D4
Pawn so white has to defend the spawn
with Knight to E2
But Here Comes the final dazzling shot
Queen to F6
and after this what else but white is
losing the Vital Center Pawn
unfortunately for white he cannot bring
the fourth Defender and that means the
game is completely corner
let me show you what happened in the
majority of the games white played the
move B5
black take on default and we have many
exchanges on D4 Knight takes D4 Knight
takes D4 Bishop takes D4 Queen takes
white even exchange the queen
where at the end when he played Rook to
C1
after Rook F to C8 there goes the second
pawn and the game
you might think hang on what can push it
right
well of course he can do it but the
problem is after Pawn takes and pawn
takes black has this lethal move Bishop
to B2 which by force wins the second
Pawn
and even though we have the opposite
color Bishop on the table
there's two distinct parser can easily
convert the full point s confirmed by
chess engine analysis here
well the same story goes if white
continue here with the move A3
trying to go for the same idea
guess what
you know what to do yup E6
and after B4
pay attention guys as Knight to E7 can
be successfully met with B5
so first you need to stop it and how we
going to stop it
it's an easy one right
you play A6 stop this nuisance
and then continue with your dancing
night Journey
first thing first White cannot play A4
here the simple reason is after Knight
takes B4
Rook to B1 looks like what is regaining
the pawn but not
a Phi and indeed Black coming out as a
pawn advantage
so A4 is right out of the equation here
that means white has to prepare B5 with
Rook to B1 and after our Knight to E7
now he can play A4 and the next move is
B5
but guess what white is one more late as
after Bishop takes F3 Bishop takes F3
and once our Knight land on fi what else
but the same old story black is winning
the pawn in the opening stage
and no matter however white Wiggles with
the careful and accurate play this is
definitely a close to winning for the
black
last but not least I like to also
mention that you can apply the same
setup against white most popular setup
let me show you what exactly it is after
our G6 white can go for Bishop to E3
Bishop to G7
Rook to Sivan and after Castle
he can play B3 which is in fact
recommended in many books and videos
very obvious
white has stopped of a bishop G4 as well
as D5 break and frustrate the whole
black opening idea
well not to worry guys as I'm going to
propose a modern move here and that is
Bishop to F5 and against this if white
is not careful then he might end up into
the same structure
for example
Bishop to E2
D5
Knight to C8 and white should Place
Bishop to F3
which goes into the different
theoretical Channel however if you look
at the database here by far Knight to F3
has been played exclusively
but after this you know what to do
yep we directly transpose to our last
line with Knight to C6
well S3 is too late here because after
Bishop to E4
we are anyways going to take the Knight
as white can't take this bishop in the
view of the D4 Pawn hangs at the end
so that is the reason why instead of H3
white has Castle
but now comes the whole point we are
going to move the bishop one more time
surprisingly it looks like a vistop
Tempo but White's move Rook to C1 is
either not a good choice
so for example S3 Bishop takes F3 Bishop
takes F3 E6
A3 Knight to E7 B4 and Knight to F5
yep the same old story Knight E2 Queen
F6 winning the important pawn and the
game
all thanks to this wonderful dancing
night
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this
wonderful night dancing trick from the
Black
remember once this Knight reach on F5 it
doesn't matter how Wayward White
wriggles
the very important deep on disappear
from the board and with that goes the
hope for the white
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will see you in my next episode
very soon
buy and take care